the rides in this country have been uh
pretty bad they've been going on for
quite a long time there was a lull in
winter as there usually is because
people don't go out when it's cold and
snowy
now things are starting to kick up a bit
earlier than they did last year in the
years before
if you've been covering uh riots if
you're a journalist who knows this you
know there's there really is like a
season for when the riots come out in
the summer when it's warm
and there's also interestingly a season
for a lot of the illegal immigration
interestingly under joe biden we're
seeing illegal immigration come sooner
and we're also seeing the riots start
sooner i don't necessarily know what
that means
but i can't tell you mainstream
politicians and personalities are
absolutely
doing everything the power to make it
worse we had maxine waters come out and
say get more confrontational
a lot of people felt like that was that
was jury intimidation now we got lebron
james putting out a tweet
saying you're next and posting a photo
of a cop
he deleted this but now it's triggering
again all sorts of controversy
jack bosobic over at oans apparently is
calling for a boycott of space jam
i think this story together is kind of
funny to talk about because it kind of
you know
meshes into the cultural issues that are
going on today so we're going to talk
about
that issue we're going to talk about you
know black lives matter showing up in
new york threatening
strangely a white guy protesting for
black lives matter threatening another
white guy it's kind of weird
but we also got some big news about
gretchen whitmer who got busted flying
to florida
she's also being sued over well in
relation to
what happened with these nursing homes a
lot of people right now are really upset
seems like andrew cuomo got away
with the nursing home deaths well
fortunately for us we have
one of the last remaining journalists on
the planet the legendary charlie laduff
hanging out in studio how's it going man
you want to introduce yourself no
[Laughter]
so uh you you basically are you're doing
this reporting on gretchen whitmer
you're calling her out for all this
corruption
i would say corruption i just i want the
truth
yeah i look you know you knew cuomo
wasn't going to get rung up this is just
politic
everything's a show it's a cycle it's a
cycle
whitmer copied everything cuomo did we
took oh
look this is what we know about covent
uh everybody out there
the institutionalized elderly got wiped
out
yeah and that's where the government is
supposed to be
looking out and if i can't get clear
data
from my governor who copied the governor
of new york
and we found out he was smoking the data
then yeah we're going to court
it's not corruption this is about how we
all live you're you might be in an old
folks home
you might be in an old folks home i
might be what about the people in there
now
what are we supposed to be doing with
all these cameras we're supposed to be
doing something
that rights the community that gets this
thing back on track that's why i said
you're one of the last journalists bro
and what is this bug sitting here
but this whole hippie compound you got
here i got stuff
oh this is the pet yeah
so we're going to talk about all this
stuff and uh you there you have a bunch
of really really famous
viral reports that you've done in the
past a lot of people are mentioning
they're familiar with your work but
just hearing you talk about this stuff
the journalists today men
they are what's the right word
stenographers for the state
they just you know whatever the governor
says is true the fbi comes out with a
statement like you got it they don't do
investigation they don't report
they're just stenographers we'll get
into all this stuff so i'm glad to have
you we got ian east china yo what up
everybody ian crossland in the house at
ian crossland
good to be here yeah yeah and me in the
corner pushing buttons my boss and my
guests have both been stinkbug tonight
it's a good night for stink bugs we're
gonna have a great night talking about
the news we uh we've started collecting
the stink bugs we put them in a jar and
we give them the chickens
they love it they love stink bugs brown
marmalade
marmara marmorated stinky they come from
china and they're invasive
but they're really dopey they like they
are from china are they because i don't
recognize them from my childhood no yeah
they're new
but they're like they're super chill you
know they'll like just like sit there
and chill and then like they'll like
move if you try to do something they
just
they don't but they don't freak you out
like because i have them in my house in
michigan they smell bad
you know you're taking a dump and there
they are and it's like you talk too i
think they were throwing them on the
window they were introduced to
pennsylvania in the 90s or something
yeah
somehow i don't know how they arrived
but then they become this invasive well
considering this isn't the stinkbug show
let's uh let's move on
so everybody knows where's the camera
that's a stink bug now you know they
look like little shields some people
call them shield bugs hold on a second
they smell like
let's find out if they're medicinal have
you ever seen someone no no did you
no he didn't do it no if you ever see
it's a trick
i saw that i intended i hate that baby
all right all right all right let me let
me let me it's almost as good
as this that's great i'm sorry it's way
better
yeah it's way better
our sponsor today is biotrust keto
elevate check out the link in the
description
it is eatrightandfeelwell.com
and you can get 51 off while supplies
last
this is medium chain triglyceride powder
you put it in your food
it provides you with energy so a lot of
people i know are super into the keto
diet
if that's something you're into this is
the kind of stuff you want to add
because let me just tell you right away
first i'm not a nutritionist
okay so this is just me reading the
internet take that for into
consideration talk to your doctor before
you do any dietary stuff
but if you are doing the keto diet a lot
of people think they just eat steak it's
like that's not keto keto is a lot of
fat
that's why you get something like this
from biotrust keto elevate mct oil ian
literally
it's so good he puts it in his coffee
yeah i just put some in does it burn fat
it is fat it is fat it's healthy fat
yeah it's like it's the good stuff it's
like
meat you don't have to eat sugars right
you really don't right so check this out
check this out
go to eat right and feelwell.com you get
51 percent off
they're big on the keto diet they say
you can get many of the benefits
elevated ketone levels without doing
keto they say if you're just eating this
stuff but let me show you some of the
talking points because they have some
really good stuff here you got a 60-day
money-back guarantee
you get enhanced energy levels so they
say a healthy appetite management
enhanced mental clarity and focus
athletic performance
they say keto elevate is the most
advanced mct powder on the market today
and free shipping on every order for
every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and it's time for a new report
it's good it's tasty i'll tell you this
because we also have the collagen from
them
i'm
this they have excellent products it
tastes like a low level sugar
really it's like mildly i mix it with my
smoothies it makes it like
it makes like i don't put cream in i'll
just put fruit but then it makes it
taste almost like a milkshake it
actually doesn't taste good if it does
all that stuff you say
i have coconut powder coconut water and
mct oil in this coffee
ian loves just every night he puts it in
i'm like ian if you're gonna put in your
coffee just wait until we do the promo
oh yeah yeah i'll put some more in well
if you want more yeah i do but anyway go
to eatrightandfeelwell.com
pick up your mct oil seriously thanks
about trust guys we're eternally
grateful for sponsors because you know
in the in the purge era we need uh all
the support we can get so biotrust
thanks so much but don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member if you click
the members area right up top you get a
bunch of exclusive members only segments
you only can watch these if you're a
member we got a huge huge library look
at all these people got michael mouse
right here
michael males dressed like superman
what's up with that we got jack murphy
there's me with a
old school i'm not going to say what
that is because you typically get mad at
me but uh you get the picture
we got to find your fairbanks we got
jeremy from the quartering teamcast.com
become a member we have big news
we have major major updates coming we're
getting news writers
this is all happening very very soon
we're working on moving as fast as we
can but uh you gotta
you know we're bursting at the seams
which means we can only move so quickly
but
thanks for all of your support everybody
and don't forget to like share subscribe
hit the notification bell
if you're listening on any podcast
platform leave us a good review we
really appreciate it
let's talk about what's going on with
lebron james
this guy's causing controversy he tweets
then deletes call for accountability
in the shooting death of columbus 16
year old mikhail bryant
james tweeted then deleted a picture
wednesday afternoon of the police
officer who was believed to have fatally
shot bryant writing
your next accountability the problem
well
i'll be a little bit more they say less
than 24 hours after he tweeted
accountability
following former minneapolis officer
derrick shobin being found guilty
lebron james took to social media again
to call for accountability in the
shooting of a 16 year old girl and now
delete a tweet
mikaya bryant a young black girl was
shot and killed by a columbus police
officer tuesday
while yielding a knife and reportedly
attempting to stab another female
brian's death has since sparked national
outrage i got to stop here and just give
my
my respect to these journalists who
literally have a video
of the woman shoving it of the 16 year
old girl shoving a woman
against the car taking the knife and thr
pulling it back and then thrusting
forward and they say
reportedly attempting to stab wielding
should be wielding
just yelling yielding a knife yeah
he was killing your knife is that does
that make sense i thought you were doing
a knife
i thought maybe you went to public
school like me and you just
read it wrong you read it wrong i didn't
i didn't go to high school i was going
to say something too
no it says you're good as that yeah it
does why did you say yielding
are you implying that the author hope
sloop from uh wkyc
went to public school as well okay well
quickly how do you spell yielding
wha why i uh e-l-d-i-e-i
why it's why i okay is there any shame
are you spelling it wrong
yeah not really i don't know i don't
know exactly
spelling it wrong no but if you write a
completely different word than what you
meant to write
it's like right it's okay not to know
nine times six
except if you're counting other people's
money that's right
so when you're on the block yep and
you're facing that
why doesn't lebron james shut up why
didn't the media shut up why didn't the
country shut up
and while we move forward in in a
process
well we're not going to blow each other
up i wish man this is not
entertainment this is killing us
yeah why is lebron james
you know you know the problem i have is
this dude when uh all this china stuff
is going down hong kong
he's he's the nba takes a side of china
over
the the protesters in hong kong
demanding freedom liberty respect
so this guy now has the nerve to come
out and it's just like
i don't know man he's just another look
if you take it out the fact that it's
lebron james
he's just another dude with twitter
right but it is lebron james
and then even lebron jay if we could
dial it down he understands
what he did that's why i deleted it well
and that's
maybe we give him some credit yeah like
maybe i went
too crazy there maybe we should calm
down
i just i don't want any war you know
what the problem is though man
the reason he says things like this i
know he deleted that's that's true so
fine like respect for deleting it for
sure right thing to do maybe he could
say
i you know i i went too far to i would
do it you know but you don't make
mistakes but look at look what's
happening now in the wake of the guilty
verdict for derrick chelvin
all of which was correct do you think
that the writer was correct guilty on
all charges
yeah i don't think so i think well
that's good guilty on all i'm not going
to hate you but you look like
it looked like murder to me dude yeah
but second degree murder like
manslaughter i understand
you know what i mean like i i i say like
you could make an argue from argument
from
first degree murder is like premeditated
yeah second
second is you did it and you knew you
were gonna do it or
you assaulted someone and they died and
third in manslaughter is an accident
right okay and third degree murder is
like you're acting in a depraved
negligent manner that results in death
it didn't look like an accident and it
didn't look like he meant to do it when
he got up in bed so what's in the middle
second degree it if if we all believe in
our process
if if we love this country and those are
the rules
oh this guy just spilled beer on the
computer don't tell him it's beer
that's fine everybody here is this would
it make it worse if it was water
probably probably got to get that off
the computer before you here i blow it
up my problem with that chauvin thing is
that
when it came out that he was a high when
uh that
that uh what's his name was high floyd
was high on yeah yeah fentanyl fentanyl
and
methamphetamine yeah and that he may
have died from like heart
cardiac arrest that maybe the cop wasn't
responsible
or not not only that but that the the
prosecution's own witness said that
chauvin wasn't was legally allowed to
use a taser and chose not to so i was
questioning whether or not like i have
reasonable doubt that
did did the cop being there do it or was
he so stressed that he would have died
on the spot anyway
i would say reasonably again
well check this out i can do that the
second degree murder charge was the
felony murder rule
that if you commit felony assault
against somebody and they die
you get charged a second-degree murder
derek chovin was convicted
under the premise that his detaining of
george floyd was felony assault on
george floyd
okay that's see you're too smart for me
i mean you're really paying attention to
this well we all i know
is i saw dude and i've been i don't know
about you guys i've had my ass beat by
the police
because that's where i come from right
yeah i saw a dude
acting in a crazy irrational manner
that's usually when police show up
but i don't expect him to be dead at the
end of it
and sometimes it does happen but i'm
looking at nine
minutes of a guy crying for his mama get
off his neck
and he did yeah well he's dead
so uh this is this is this is the thing
i think a lot of people
uh like i followed the trial i watched
the trial most people probably didn't
derek chauvin's knee was not
consistently on floyd's neck yeah
he should have spoke for himself yeah
like i i lost it i i blanked out i have
stress
you know you should have said something
for yourself got a constitutional right
to the fifth amendment
you absolutely do and you you decided to
take that
and now i thought you said it really
interesting now he was going to jail no
matter what and this is the point
when you see prison prison right prison
for life
so it's not a life conviction but all
the years combined
lebron james tweeting this right we have
a whole bunch of left-wing activists
saying in no uncertain terms the only
reason chauvin was convicted is because
they burned the city down
that's not justice no it's dumb ass to
burn the city down but they did
but so figuratively like they burned out
a bunch of different buildings in the
city and smashed a bunch of windows
whenever you say they burn this idiot
down you get all these journalists being
like
false minneapolis is still a city it
still exists did we mean they burned
down a bunch of buildings calm down
you wanted to say brother yeah you said
earlier that it's not this isn't
entertainment man
this people are treating this like
reality tv it and it's destroying
people it's making people they're
they're forgetting that it's
real life and no it they live on the
internet bro
yeah that's true right but there's a
swath of america where it's really
important
whether it be black america
or blue america and all in between
to some people it's really serious to
too many of us
it's a ratings grab yeah and i don't
want to be that guy
i want to be the guy that tries to bring
something
you used to work at the new york times
and where else fox and
were you the kind of guy that chased
ratings in the beginning of your career
i've never chased ratings never i just
figured if you did go work
it would do what it would do and mostly
journalism right doesn't get any ratings
so you don't have to worry about it you
can just be in the crowd with everybody
that i'll change though in the past
several years yeah but now tell me
you might get ratings but who's doing
anything that lasts
look at anything we're talking about
anything we're watching
tell me you out there any of this stuff
are you going to show your grandchildren
one thing you're going to put in your
drawer
and go i was alive there dude
the likelihood that any of these
journalists i'm doing air quotes would
show their grandchildren the things
they've done in terms of their work is
laughable
could you imagine an 80 year old guy
being like come here little billy
this is when i wrote five pictures of
brad pitt's
junk i won an internet award for that
one
oh billy billy billy billy gonna be in a
book i'd like to
i met your grandmother when i worked at
buzzfeed here's an article she wrote
where she said
trump is literally worse than hitler i
really don't think they're going to be
going to their grandkids and being proud
of that stuff
i got to say i mean to make it all about
me
my time at the new york times my wife
kept everything i wrote
and she cut them and she put them in
these big gigantic clip books
so there's three of these things that's
what i'm saying they're like for my
great-grandchildren
and then all the stuff i wrote for the
new york times was bound in a book
and they've translated into polish and
it's coming out so i feel
like i just wrote about you know nice
guy
uh nick and uh easy eddie and regular
people
and that's the word the stuff
if you're doing uh what would you call
it like human interest pieces
all of it you take human interest plus
news and you rap it into
something that somebody wants to read is
consumable
this is the thing you know if they were
writing articles where it's like
you know jenny's genesis bakery won an
award the community is very happy
i think that stink focus making you feel
safe yeah
spilled the beer uh if you were a story
that wasn't particularly globally
consequential
but it was a good story about the
community and about the things going on
i think that's something you want to
show your kids so your grandkids but
these people at some of these news
outlets writing about brad pitt's junk
and like
you know what was there one article it
was like written by some feminists like
uh what did she call it it was like guys
with tight pants you could see their
junk
yep and it was like look at all these
guys in tight pants i'm like
congratulations that journalism degree
is paying off
but you know the problem the next guy's
in tight pants but here's the thing
journalism has become a ratings industry
you know so they they want the clicks
they want the ads well necessarily so
because the underpinnings of it
have disappeared so you now you now got
to give people what they want
so there is a responsibility of people
to
back in the day was it like one really
wealthy person would subsidize a company
to
to study and and you know report on
anything regardless of its popularity or
clickbaityness it's a combination of
factors marketing was a big was a big
play
so i think what uh i don't know yeah
definitely
um reuters do you know about the history
of reuters
thompson reuters my understanding is
that the news
department was just an advertising for
like legal documents or something i
don't know the foster so i'm probably
getting it wrong
but uh i've been i've been to their
headquarters a couple times my
understanding was that they had they
have a private business
and the news outlet advertised their
business so that was that was a big
thing
these newspapers would sell ads in the
papers they'd sell the paper itself
so if you're selling the paper you're
covering your costs you're selling ads
you're making more money
and the only place to get media was in
these papers then
you want to sell as many papers as
possible when you're competing with only
a small handful of you know
very powerful and big newspapers in a
major city you got to make sure you're
reaching a certain number of people
so for a period news outlets were trying
to hit the lowest common denominator
that meant the news coverage was always
fairly close to the middle because they
didn't want to fend the left they didn't
want to offend the right
so they had to keep it fairly balanced
if they want to maximize the amount of
views they were going to get
nowadays you get infinite choices you go
online you can get your news from
anybody yeah
so now everyone's like screw it let's
just go give me what i want
they're they're they're investors who
will invest in a company that does
nothing but crazy far left of stuff
crazy far right wing stuff and they're
like i got my finger in both outlets so
i'm making money i don't care
right exactly exactly you know what i
know about reuters when they built the
new reuters building in times square
i was their soup to nuts and i did a
series of stories
on the iron workers the guys that lay
the steel
and the mohawk indians have been
building the skyscrapers in new york
since 1900 wow and there's a whole
um sort of book about there's a whole
genre about them and i took it to them
and i said did you
do you know these guys well that was my
grandpa cool well that was my uncle
what happened to him he fell and he died
and i wrote the next
chapter in that so i don't know about
reuters
but i know that i captured the mohawk
indians
in the next generation and that's what i
like to do you know you know i think one
of the problems with news is
it doesn't need to be the biggest story
that's going to change the world
where you're going to win you're going
to be put up on stage and everyone's
going to cheer for you and clap it just
has to be good stories
stories that that are important for a
variety of reasons sometimes there's
stories that
are uplifting inspire people sometimes
they're calling out bad behavior from
politicians
exposing corruption and too much of the
journalism we have today you can't even
call it journalism it's tabloid trash
it's uh um you know listicles that's why
they're coming here
they'd like to be talk somebody be
straight with me they i'm sure
definitely these hundreds of thousands
of people listen they don't agree with
everything you're saying
no mostly like it was funny we had will
chamberlain here and i'm like there's a
little chamberlain
here yeah yeah yeah not not wilt
chamberlain not the stilt
yeah yeah will chamberlain oh oh oh well
the attorney will yeah the the
conservative uh
he runs human events.com but uh he ain't
no will chamberlain i'll just tell you
that right now
will chambers we disagreed and everybody
in the super chats are like tim you're
wrong tim you're wrong timmy wrong
will's will's right
but i guess so long as you know i'll
i'll tell you something
that people like when you brought up
your
your position on uh derek chauvin and
then i
presented a counter point you said well
you know more than i do that's the kind
of attitude people expect
from what journalists are supposed to
have that if you if you have an opinion
on something you're willing to say okay
well i'll learn more about it and you
know you're calling me the journalist
i'm a reporter bro reporter
um honest guy i wanna know the
difference honest guy how about that
what's the difference i do my best but
the difference between a journalist and
a reporter is a journalist
went to ivy league no i'm just i need
i know i'm gonna get that bs from a
journalist can type without looking
reporters do it with fingers a a
reporter
drinks with the public yeah in public
and a journalist drinks in private with
the public official
that's what so this whole thing about
journalism
it's r you're a reporter that's all you
are
yeah but these people over at cnn
they're the ones sitting there those
guys
i mean look at cuomo's brother is cuomo
on cnn
fredo fredo fredo what a phony all right
dude i've been in the basement
i'm coming up
on your bicycle your brother's over
there writing a book and throwing
all people and the nursing homes will
infect other old people
garbage garbage garbage
that's what we don't need sorry that's
my yeah i 100 agree with everything you
just did
yes but that's the point these are
journalists
they complain every day about the the
insults and the threats against
journalists when they're literally the
brothers of corrupt government officials
who do bits with giant q-tips instead of
actually telling people and they lie
about having did you
ever chris me you
i've never seen you on the block you're
a rich kid
i never saw you do any reporting did you
ever go to a nursing home
because i went to the nursing homes and
i picked up
the dead bodies with the body collector
to get a look at the nursing homes did
you
i mean you're not the moralizer dude i
don't know who you are
i didn't grow up with you i didn't no
he's the guy who covered it up
come on man and i got it's not political
it's fake theater and we don't need it
do some work if you got the work i'll
believe you
if you can present it with some pizzazz
then i like you
you are preaching to the choir yes and
they're all cheering for what you're
saying
the the the new the media industry in
this country is just a bunch of people
who are
like i said what stenographers for the
state aren't that you got to pay
you know if you don't pay then you're
not going to get the highest quality
because to defend
the current reporter they got them doing
18 things a day
you know that you are a stenographer the
governor said this
you don't even got time to check out
what the governor said was right
yeah you're just pushing it i'm against
it but you do have to assume anything
trump would say was wrong
yeah that was that was the other trump's
a mess for sure
trump's a mess but there's some things
he did
that were correct like the vaccines here
but how about
how about for some reason the media
always
said he was wrong like come on broken
clock is right twice a day if you're
saying he's wrong all the time so we got
problems well
the majority of the media did the one's
wearing the blue jacket
right that's right and then the ones
wearing the red jacket said it could do
no wrong
what about us who we're the vests we're
just here in the middle they're
trying to get along but they're gone bro
it's like the
no no it's the audience and it's us yeah
we're not
gone that's true we're not we just want
something
i'll put it this way the the guys in the
red jackets
you know they they work for smaller and
much less
ubiquitous news outlets they're not the
prominent mainstream corporate meeting
in this country
what what are you talking about fox news
fox news is one channel you got cbs nbc
abc
well unless i i didn't say it was
everybody knows that
they're mainstream media for sure yeah
so but reporters are mainly
liberal but i know i worked at the new
york times but i'm agreeing with you
i voted for obama twice what i'm saying
is and ronald reagan
you have much fewer of the guys in the
red jackets and the guys in the blue
jackets
yeah but here's the thing how about
everybody take off the jackets and just
do what's supposed to be done
sometimes the guy in the red jacket's
wrong and you're wearing a red jacket
that's right so you're supposed to be
wearing a non-collared shirt
when you're doing what we're doing
you're just regular
well now you gotta call it as you see it
based in fact
but check this out you got people like
matt taibbi glenn greenwald and michael
tracy are you familiar with those guys
matt's a friend of mine yeah exactly
those are those are the legit guys that
are wearing the vest there's very few
people actually doing journalism but
they're the guys who'll come out and say
something like
you know trump was right about this that
and this but wrong about all these other
things and trump's got attitude problems
as it should be done but why is it when
you go to the new york times you go to
cnn they're wearing the blue jackets
yeah look i get it i'm not answering for
him if fox news is wearing red jacks
experitorial do we get
no no it's not conspiracy but it's money
we're trying to guess who they are
you know like yeah exactly you were
ground zero
as a security guard yeah and i was at
ground zero
as a reporter and
somewhere in there is the story
not so much you know uh the city
councilman today said that that there's
smoke from grazie
no there were molten there was rivers of
molten steel for months after the
building came down
underneath the pile just molten steel
flowing for months
remember that i want some physics behind
did you ever see
a door knob did you ever see a urinal
no i didn't love it they were
means a lot to me i'm older
it's the 20-year anniversary of 9 11 and
if you could
maybe throughout the summer think about
it
read something about remember some of
the names that would be cool because
we're going to get it for again the
media we're going to get it for one day
the big
ribbon-cutting and parading speech and
it's so much more than it
it's all of us regular people that was
our day
those who died the secretaries and those
that came to pick them up
the firemen the cops the regular dudes
with long hair
just guys from queens trying to do right
remember that
now think about this somebody today
who's 26 years old
doesn't remember any of it no i know
they're a little kid that's cool
but now they're reporters for these news
outlets they don't get it they don't
understand you know what they do
that's funny they compare covid
to 9 11. kovan's a natural occurrence
until we find out about the chinese lab
911 was mass murder and then
it launched a bunch of bad stuff and a
bunch of bad mistakes and we're still in
afghanistan
[Music]
that is a whole different deal so
remember young people
well so this is one of the big issues
affecting journalism today
and people are starting to finally get
it cause i'm wondering like we we had uh
this this lefty guy on the show
what's his name vosh is he all right i
think well i completely disagree with a
lot of his opinions did he have a tail
did what did he have a tailor no no he's
a normal guy he was a normal guy
yeah all right he's good he's good uh we
had a long long argument and i think one
of the important things that came up was
like when i would reference occupy wall
street
he was like oh i was a teenager i
remember any of that that was brilliant
by the way what was
occupied wall street oh yeah so so look
i'm down there and i'm in my 20s
i remember all this stuff he was a
teenager who wasn't paying attention to
politics
so what happens when you get somebody
who doesn't understand the financial
crisis
the war in iraq and afghanistan 911 and
now they're prominent media
personalities influencing more young
people
it's no surprise you have a lot of young
people who have a particular political
persuasion
and they're all kind of in agreement
with each other around the same age
because they don't remember the same
things we remember right they don't
remember what joe biden did or barack
obama did
during those years no offense to them so
when i write right so when i'm like
here's why i don't like joe biden and
i'll reference maybe like the actual
extra judicial assassinations that obama
carried out with the killing of anwar
al-awlaki abdul rahman
is two very prominent uh notable
instances
they don't remember that they were like
i was 13. i have no idea one of the most
important parts is
is witnessing the militarization of the
united states after 9 11. like 1998 we
were not
under we were not a military dude dude
you could go into an airport
you could stand at the gate and wait for
your family to come out it was great and
we weren't at war it was crazy dude and
then after 2002
now they can i think they can drone bomb
any american citizen at any time with
the patriot act legally
yeah that's insanity it's called
extrajudicial assassination
there will be no che guevara anymore
there won't that revolution business
is over it is because we have drones we
got all
facial recognition so you can go
downtown
and burn stuff up you can go to the
capitol
and break she'll find you i
and you can do that baboonery at the
capitol
but it's not getting us anywhere
don't do those things but i think to
your
point we saw a year of people going and
burning down buildings across this
country
and tear it up to capital but tearing up
the capital those people have the fbi
putting up billboards the fbi saying
find out who they are they're going
through facial recognition they're
finding each and every single person
because that's the capital that's right
that's difficult
gucci store is different to me than the
capital well no but they firebombed
federal buildings
you know they were throwing explosives
so i'm sure they're getting them i know
they got a few
they cut them loose the prosecutor in
portland caught off i think it was like
four felony charges for for firebombing
uh i don't know the specific charges but
something related to that uh one one was
one was felony assault on an officer
so these people they caught they
arrested they charged and then as soon
as baden got in the prosecutor was like
all right you're free to go
well i like portland i do i really like
a lot
my kind of people but uh if this is what
you're
wanting beware that's my attitude i'm
like i don't know i don't live in
portland so at this point
you know i can i can complain about the
double standard for sure we all can if
they're if they're only going after one
group of people and they're ignoring
other group of people it's like we gotta
have equality under the law
but i'll tell you this right now my
attitude on the police
at this point if people voted for
abolishing the police
and all of our arguments fell flat
nobody's doing that
minneapolis some more tweety stuff no no
no no minneapolis literally voted to
abolish the police
when was that uh end of uh city council
fall of last year
and they backed off it but they they
already lost a bunch of the officers
i know then they started dumping money
to try and get them back exactly
now they're arresting and charging the
cops like kim you see the kim potter
thing right
why'd he get a name job kim potter shout
out to kevin you know you know the
shooting with dante right
yes so this guy oh yes yes there's
so many of them well the taser right
right
but so so let's go through this real
quick real quick
this guy's wanted for aggravated robbery
with a deadly weapon so that's
that's what aggravated robbery is right
he had a ruger 45 he gets pulled off
yeah he's one of he's got a warrant on
it because he was carrying the piece no
he was he had a
warrant for robbing a woman at gunpoint
right so now they also had a misdemeanor
a gross misdemeanor warrant for the
question is
once again there's a warrant for him
robbing somebody with a weapon so what
he made bail
no he skipped uh he skipped so he made
bail
no no no he threatened this woman yeah
and then he fled she called the police
they should have warned for his arrest
okay he skipped a bail on the gun charge
so he didn't i don't think he realized
yeah he never was bail he was
right he was never arrested in the first
place
so he gets pulled over and i think he
didn't realize so when they were like
out of the car he says for what
according to his mom
they get him out of the car they cuff
him and then he starts resisting he
pulls off
dives into the car and then they're
wrestling with him
and then the cop kim potter says taser
taser taser she's holding her gun though
the cop moves she fires one shot and
into dante right he drives off the
bullet kills him he crashes he dies
is it justified to use deadly force
against somebody who's wanted
for an aggravated robbery charge who was
previously known to be in possession of
a
ruger 45 who resists arrest jumps into
their car and starts reaching for
something or doing something out of
sight
should the officer then defend
themselves and the lives of others you
want me to
you want me to play god here
again that's why we have a process now i
i've got the basics and i saw some video
i can't be that guy i will tell you what
i do know about
life i know that a cop
pulls them over and said he's wanted on
a gun charge so immediately they think
he's got
some proclivity maybe they can be be on
the lookout
they're talking they want to arrest me
dives in a car
immediately immediately i'm leaning
immediately the cops already on high
alert
i don't know what you're reaching for
who the hell dives into a car
i don't dive into a car i get pulled
over
i'm not the darkest guy my hands are
here yep
okay i i know what's going on in america
i don't dive in a car
i don't know but i i know cops
repetitively
pull their firearm they don't pull taser
they don't practice that much with taser
but again it tells me maybe sitting on
my couch
she's not the most seasoned person on
the street
i think you see what i'm saying i think
people listen so i don't
want to burn and i don't want to
fight well but i will so here's
here's the issue it's there's no easy
answer to these things so why are we
trying to get one
why are we doing that in what way what
do you mean like so what do i think of
it i
i think it's confusing and we got to let
it it was right next to
you know minneapolis where the trial is
going on so that's just
it's it's high alert the point is
the point is so long as they keep
burning cities down
nothing burned though this time nothing
burned in brooklyn center
they smashed up a bunch of windows cops
basements and one of the jurors in the
chauvin trial lived there and they had
to drive through a city full of boarded
up windows
maxine waters said if we don't get our
convictions and they weren't sequestered
for that that one was
so crazy so listen how are we so how are
we supposed to have the law enforced if
you got some guy who threatens a woman
at gunpoint for 800
cash and then should the cops go and
arrest this person i'm not
i'm i'm not asking you i'm saying
rhetorically my my position is well yeah
we can't have people going around doing
that
if the person then resists arrest and
jumps into their car should the officer
then just
submit and be like oh i might get shot i
guess or do we ask to get in that way
that's my point so at this point i think
the only reasonable solution for
cops and for the people in the cities is
to leave because if you live in an area
where this kind of stuff is happening
between riots
look if you think cops killing people is
a problem and the the cops are now going
to get arrested in
any instance where there's a police
involved shooting like so so going back
real quick to the lebron james thing
this 16 year old
girl who got shot was literally pulling
the knife back ready to
shoot or ready to stab somebody and the
cop shot her in defense of another woman
and the people there immediately got mad
at the cop and called him a murderer
i don't see it i don't see how you could
be a smart person and think staying on
the job makes sense
when everybody wants you to leave
regardless of whether or not you or i or
anyone thinks it's right or wrong
cops probably shouldn't be doing any of
it if people say you're a murderer for
trying to arrest someone for aggravated
robbery
maybe you should stop doing that because
the public court of public opinion is
clearly not on your side and you're
gonna go to prison
i will say two things
lebron james is wrong he knew he was
wrong
and i'm gonna cut him some break here so
the man can grow
because again i don't want to fight more
than we already are
two we we do have a problem with police
i don't it's a it's not a majority of
police
we have a problem we got to fix it
then i'll say this i know this i know
the measurements
but half of all people that die at the
hands of cops
are white it's like sixty-one percent i
think isn't it sixty-one percent
sixty-five could be wrong sixty percent
of the country's white
twenty percent is latino and twelve
percent is black
fifty percent of the deaths by cops are
white
twenty percent of the deaths of latinos
and thirty percent of black so the
latinos
are dropped by their proportion the
whites almost and the blacks two and a
half times
more there's a lot underlying that is
the big problem
i would submit this to you what kind of
latino people
what kind of white people it's a class
issue yes it is study will show you
the less bread you got the more rowdy
you are
if you're from my corner of the world
that's what we do
we party when you get loud and rowdy the
police show up
i'm not diminishing a traffic stop and
i'm not diminishing
what what happened with george floyd oh
no no that's murder i said it
straight up i think i think shelby got
what he deserved
but if we could come together because
remember the rednecks
at the capitol what were they doing if
the police pig
right they really showed what they
thought about law enforcement but you
know why that was
i don't i wasn't there well so we had a
we have this this year of lockdowns
where small businesses have cops show up
barricade the doors arrest
people beat people arrest families for
violating covert restrictions
and then you started seeing these
conservatives these right-wing
individuals throwing the blue lives
matter in the
flag and the the blue lives matter flag
and the dirt stepping on it because the
cops those conservatives
yes no no those weren't yet they were
those were a-holes dude throwing the
blue lives matter really like uh i was
locked up and i'm angry
well are we asking people to have some
personal responsibility
and aren't they included oh no way
no no no no man okay when they shut down
misunderstandings
when they lock down churches and set the
cops in new york to go arrest jewish
people
and weld only the jewish people another
problem
you got people coming out saying the
cops were disproportionately enforcing
unconstitutional restrictions and even
when the supreme when you when you get
like the courts
telling cuomo telling whitmer telling
wolf and pa to stop doing this
they would say i'll just do a new
executive order you can't stop me so at
a certain point
the people on the right were like yo
cops why are you enforcing what the
courts have already said no to
and so they start throwing the boulevard
flags in the dirt then when it comes
down to january 6 these people have no
respect for cops they don't care
well you know because i know a lot of
cops cops treated me well during covet
cops went to work in fact
here's where it's at as i see it as a
reporter and as
a man and a citizen
the only government that even responds
to you anymore in this country
is the police or the paramedic or the
firefighter
do me a favor now everybody call your
congress person see if you get a call
back
call your mayor call your city council
person they
only come calling on election season so
we've asked the people
i don't know where you're from but of my
class
the paramedics the cops of firemen to do
all the work of the government
which is of the high class and they
don't answer us
they just send factories overseas
right they give their nieces jobs and we
we're over here with our pants around
our ankles
our restaurants are closed and you can't
explain you're coming into my shule
you're not letting me go to my mass and
you don't understand
the problem amongst other things race is
a problem everybody knows that
it's green there's no green in this
country and we're faking the green now
printing fakery yeah
that's a that's a whole other worm can i
mean talking about
the inflation the mass inflation by a
bank by the federal reserve i said it
no oversight everyone take a drink no
just kidding
uh drink responsibly yeah yeah yeah and
and how that's devaluing our currency
creating more poverty more class
diversity
uh more stress that's causing could lead
to more
unrest i mean these people there's no
oversight that's in that
that i think is the is the real issue i
got i got to i got to just
just call out personal responsibility
like if if there are cops
who want to enforce if look if you've
got people on the right and they're
saying
we don't agree oh there he goes
if you got david koresh never did it
like this bro no
you got so we have uh we have what's up
energy drinks
so if you got people on the right and
they're saying we don't want the cops to
enforce
what the community opposes and the cops
say we don't care if there's people who
are like we just want to
cut hair and the cops show up to a small
town in michigan and arrest some dude
or give him a fine because he was given
haircuts yeah the barber of a wasp
right you got people on the right saying
stop doing this the cops say
shut up we don't care then why would
these people keep supporting the police
you got a first amendment right to
peaceably assemble let me put it and to
speak
let me put this way in detroit my
capital city
it's the spiritual capital it's the
biggest city of michigan i know lansing
is a capital but detroit is the capital
a cop that starts that job ready drum
roll
you got it lightly on the table 38
thousand dollars
wow america's most violent city thirty
eight thousand dollars who in their
right mind would do that
we defunded the police in detroit when
we did the bankruptcy
we took their salary we took a piece of
their pension we took to medical when
they retire
so if you want good police you got to
pay
and we need police you need high caliber
people
you need to pay for mental health for
them yes
do they go see me does any community
around here
require the police to go see a counselor
just get it off your chest
it's hard benefits
we don't have anything get used to it
watch i suspect things are going to get
worse
something like 260 police departments
got defunded last year
or less funded they got their funding
removed
so completely removed yeah well no no
poor like defunded
meaning that they were taking portions
of their budget away like nypd lost i
think like a billion
like like 20 something percent of their
budget yeah this was predominantly
progressives calling for defunding the
police
maybe it's because we don't have tax
revenue
could it be a sleight of hand we're
playing the political game
and yet we're broke because look at the
look at the federal government
yeah where's it putting that money what
did we just print in the last year why
is there such a thing as a black
trillion or something 40 percent of all
currency out there
made in the last year was made in the
last presidency the charts look insane
well we
we must not be depressed we must be
educated and right on
and we must figure out a way
to respect each other come together i
know this sounds like a
sermon but i i do believe
that good reporting can give a good
reflection
of what's happening to us how do you
deal with
a multi-billion dollar news industry
that makes their money off inflaming
tensions between political faction
between classes between races
i left i don't know what you're doing i
left yeah we started we started our own
thing
yeah no bs news hour no bs news
that's your show yeah i guess i guess
what you got to do you got to get away
with the plug
oh yeah yeah we'll shout it out much
more too that's a good way become an
example of an
of a another option what you
you want to go run to john real quick
yeah go to it to it we'll talk about
we'll talk about uh jackpot and space
jam
i might sneak a cigarette with your
hippies down there
quick who turned me on to put in coffee
uh
peanut butter powder and coffee and my
in my coffee brilliant
butter powder yeah you got that peanut
butter powder a scoop of that
all right ladies and gentlemen we got
pioneer we got the story on jackpot
thanks poso bounding into comics reports
oan
host jack posobic calls for boycott of
space jam
a new legacy after lebron james
threatened police
i don't know if he's serious which is
funny i think he's joking but i love how
these tweets just end up getting news
coverage
so peace promoter poso is his name
boycott space jam lebron threatens
police
all right the call to boycott the film
comes after james posted a photo of a
cop on twitter
he captioned the photo writing your next
accountability
yikes james did delete his uh his tweet
as pacific points out he writes
hi lebron james why did you delete this
the photos of officer
nicholas written this we get all right
okay space jam a new legacy is being
distributed by at t on warner brothers
blah blah blah
do plan on taking up posobik's call and
boycotting space jam a new legacy after
lebron james threatened
a columbus police officer who prevented
a stabbing i'm assuming they meant to
say do you plan to right
yeah i mean i just read the articles as
their presentation is copy editing
yeah seriously give me a break i didn't
even know there was a space jam
happening this is the first i've heard
of it
why do i i don't want to watch it anyway
what is it a remake well hold on i'm
going to pretend i want to watch it and
say i'm boycotting it
there you go i do want to watch space
jam i love the og space jam i'm a huge
fan of it actually
yeah no i i had no plan on watching this
bunch okay i'm not going to watch it
i wouldn't have watched this i'm not
going to boycott a boycott
i'm back big fan of space jam i didn't
wash my hands that was
so bad quick speed is of the essence
just protect us oh
are you a space jam fan no man did you
see the first one
with michael jordan and bugs bunny yeah
yeah oh come on grow
up that's silly yeah um so that were
they remaking the
original or sorry oh that's right you
were children when that came out
yes yes it was good okay of course you
loved it when this came out and they had
they had the burger king cups or
whatever yeah what was it they had like
the glass jar
yeah it was fun and i would i would uh i
was so excited to go see that in the
movies
i think it was like 40 years old yeah i
was like yeah you're like
nah you must have been your nah you must
be 93 or something yeah i was like 94 94
it was i was just at the age where i
could realize it was like
really cheap propaganda it just seemed
like propaganda just seemed like
what they were using a basketball player
to sell a product
what wasn't like a movie he wasn't a
good actor michael jordan
oh you're supposed to move you're saying
that they put them in a movie for the
sake of selling tickets to a movie yeah
yeah
yeah but i thought it was kind of cool
but i didn't see the movie that they
took sort of like
this the mary poppins model and brought
it back with michael jordan yeah you
take
animation yeah and in real because
that's not really
who framed roger rabbit was in that time
yeah at least when i i remember that
exactly
so they reinvented a genre so this one
is just a
it's just how much money you need it was
really high budget too who you know you
know this is four
they're trying to target people like
between my age and ian's age who have
kids
who are going to be like who loved it i
remember space jam i want to take my
kids to see space jams
this is an example of cultural decay
heavy
[Music]
give me a more modern christmas song um
i'm
dreaming what year was that song let me
finish
christmas uh 1945.
yeah can you try another more modern
christmas song oh
santa got run over by rain hey what year
was that
60s yeah so how come i can keep going
we we i think i think the most modern i
can think of is all i want for christmas
is you bye
really really old we're not writing new
music our movies are regurgitations
it's not changing we're not making new
things we're not inspiring people
we are just saying i'm going to do what
i did when when i was a kid again with
my kids
instead of hey let's write a new concept
a new movie a new song let's
let's change it up we're stagnating
exactly culture is decaying when's the
last great uh protest song since
kendrick lamar
i mean you know look we're living in it
where's the music man
it's too corny in court where's the
writing bro bro bro when when when the
biggest protest moves
hold on hold on when the biggest protest
movement is on the same side as walmart
and amazon right i don't think those are
protest songs right
i think those are corporate jingles yeah
i wrote a
christmas song it's called it's
christmas time it's on youtube
um that's it and hum a few bucks i wrote
it ian wrote it it's christmas time
something something song i don't even
know you're wrong
i haven't listened to it in like 12
years but i wrote it it's it's
it's too it could be refined i'll say
this i'll say this
don't boycott space jam because lebron
james tweeted something dumb
boycott regurgitations demand something
new
thank you or you know what
maybe check it out when it comes to
netflix i mean i'm
i'm not going to be i don't want no
netflix doesn't do that anymore okay but
you know
well i guess it come out of netflix
maybe check it out and tell everybody
else that sucks
look i'm a sucker i still get kentucky
fried chicken
i will go to taco bell wait are they
sponsors of the show
no i won't go to taco i'll go back to
taco bell once you sponsor this show
but i do do that i'm not a purist
yeah sometimes you got to use the
corrupt system to fix the corruption i'm
part of it man
no no we're you're making something new
you're doing the no bs newshour
you got something new we're doing
something new we are going to funding
shows we should hook up we should you
want to do news let me know and we'll
we'll get some good news going on yeah
we're going to do news we're going to do
shows we're going to do comedy we're
going to do movies we're going to do
sci-fi
because i'm because i'm sick and tired
of every single thing
it's been years man since what was
you know what i liked the marvel
cinematic universe the superhero movies
yeah but come on they're just making
movies out of comics from 70 years ago
yeah
yeah but at least i don't got to read
them now sure sure
it's it's it's a great modern adaptation
of something that's really really old
at a certain point stan lee jack kirby
these guys were like how about a guy who
turns green and gets real strong when
he's mad
well actually i think he originally
turned gray but you know you get the
point how about a guy who can jump over
tall buildings and for some reason he
has like eyes breath
it was they made something up and they
worked on it it became popular because
they worked on it
now everybody is just trying to say i
don't want to do the work i want what
he's got
let me inherit your wealth and i'm not
going to make something new
these companies don't want to take the
risks they don't want to make new
exciting things because
it's a potential risk i got one i got
one
yeah christmas old movies being made
into new movies
old books right maybe why can't we get a
new
ten commandments oh i'm so excited i
like that movie
yeah yeah yeah yeah the movie ten
commandments yeah i do charlton has
found
the ten commandments oh remake i thought
you meant to actually write ten new
commandments
okay that works too yeah that is i think
more even more important i don't know
about that we'll discuss it look at the
commandments yeah the manila principles
why don't they redo that
that could be a pretty sweet i would
love to play that role
you you look like you're getting the
redoing doom wait jesus doesn't come
till later
moses says listen i want to ask you
something jesus when did you get
white uh it took about 2 000 years
from what i heard it took the romans
yeah that's right they're they're
they're redoing dune ian's really
excited for that oh dude yes
dude oh yeah but i heard it might be
woke um oh really
yeah i don't know many details dune did
you read it dune
wait is that the one it was like a
famous 80s isn't it yeah yeah early 80s
uh lynch did one david lynch did it
wasn't it the dude from the police uh
i don't know yeah sting was in it sting
he played a big flap yeah
he was actually really good in that it
was a weird lynch movie but sting was
awesome
was it a big flap it was yeah they tried
they gave they did monologues like long
monologues which don't translate to film
they're good in theater and in books
they make a lot of sense but not
they were doing inner monologues yeah it
was really really really weird
just show his face and he's thinking and
you hear his voice for like
three minutes it's so boring yeah they
tried to make a
book into a movie without making it a
movie and then in the 90s they did one
with william hurt
and dune made for tv movie but they
translated all that monologue into
dialogue and it made it way
more interesting we just need new stuff
that's what we're doing oh so we we we
put our vlog got
age restricted yes what's up with that
what ages what what happened what
we made we made a vlog from the house
showing people the house because
the point is one of the things i'm big
on is we got to make culture which means
you can't just sit around and complain
about politics because politics is
downstream from culture right
you need to make stuff to inspire people
and build community
and so i'm like we're going to do that
we're going to start a vlog we started a
vlog we got this program
this joint yeah yeah so we got the ramps
we got the outdoors no this place is a
trip
totally no you walk in here unexpected i
walked in today like
what the hell is going on it's great
everybody
barefoot their their computers going up
they're they're
finding your ipn they're doing ipm we
got
talking about dracula i mean it was like
what we launched
we got bows and arrows outside oh we
launched race cars over the garage going
like 60 miles an hour
and we put up this vlog and youtube age
restricted it no you can't you can't
you can't oh we're not showing that no
you can't it's not real
as far as you know youtube so uh it's an
antique
that's not an antique what's not an
enzyme that's real
what is so we have a vlog that age
restricted it
and so that's i guess that's that's
that's i just particularly annoying i
thought
what does that mean exactly you have to
be signed in 18 years old to watch the
vlog
and that's because they think that's
actually kind of cool no it's bad it
means you can't put on other websites
and you can't share it
okay but you're creating a new culture
so you know what if
what that vlog is saying is for real
come find it just lean into it yeah
maybe we can't make it easy for you
give some effort right that's why they
put a restriction on it because they
don't want us to actually influence
people to be free
independent thinkers who want to build
and create and inspire others that's why
i don't mind
people taking to the streets man just
don't tear it up i agree man
peaceful protest somebody mess with you
drop them i mean i think
would be peaceful be disruptive but not
violent not destructive
disruptive means like you kind of annoy
people when you're marching down the
street and you're kind of you know in
the way a little bit
it were it worked with mlk and it worked
with gandhi
mlk got things a lot farther than what
malcolm x was saying but never doing
they they they set buildings on fire
they caused two billion dollars in in
damage and they got their conviction
yeah the insurance company you know the
old argument no no no
the buildings in minneapolis couldn't be
rebuilt because the cost of rubble
removal exceeded the the the liability
insurance coverage
well it's funny one of the building i
won't won't name the companies but one
of the buildings that got torn up
got a sweet deal a sweet package
sweet tax abatements and subsidies
from the city of minneapolis to build
it's a multinational
yeah why is why are we doing that
how did this happen correct a main line
to the mayor's ear
well it's become american culture now
i'll leave if you don't give me
your children's breakfast you know
my child's school my child you know we
do okay so my child doesn't get the
federal breakfast program
but i'm an elder i'm a man in this
community i go see we're defeating the
kids
generic pop-tarts and orange drink
our money now i am not i
think we all have to feed our children
right i'm not gonna feed your dad for
his whole life but the kid ain't going
hungry
not as long as i'm living on the earth
how is it i paid you reached in my
pocket
for orange juice it went to washington
it went to lansing it went to the school
board
and magically my tax money for that
child
the orange juice transmogrified into
orange
drink some contract yeah
it's like food coloring sugar and
vitamin c
so it's okay so they were supposed to
buy orange juice
that's what i bought orange drinks why
are we feeding our kids
orange drink and generic pop-tarts when
you could be giving them
uh biotrust that's
in hospitals they fed patients healthy
food instead of
amazing instead of sweet drink yeah it's
they think about
a hospital a place of healing and they
they feed people the same kind of stuff
they feed in public schools
where do money go there are a lot of
rich people eating a lot of fancy meals
i'll tell you that
a lot of blue coat media sitting down
public officials
being stenographers for them and having
fancy dinners you know i love about the
media that hangs out with the swells
they think they're a swell they also
think they're a swell
but you know what i always say you're a
you're a
hound you're a poodle laying at the
table waiting for a scrap to fall off
ain't nobody listening to you not when
the times get real
you think they are anybody out there
reading the local business magazine
yeah i think uh
just just to cycle back uh that the
sugar industry is
subsidizing like the government in such
a way that they're pumping
sugar into the schools and the hospitals
and the prisons
and that's why we see orange drink
there's some contractor isn't there
there's always a contractor let's talk
about what's going on with uh
with whitmer yes because let's get into
this this big thing you're working on
so we have the story we got this one
from click on detroit michigan governor
whitmer blasts criticism over visiting
sick father in florida
state leader reacts to criticism and
interview with the washington post or
she runs to the washington post
right they're they're very favorable
towards democrats click on
detroit you didn't cover it sorry guys
you hearing me
you didn't cover it and then click on
his writing the governor
of michigan went to the washington post
yeah so what's up with this story
apparently she was criticizing people
who traveled criticizing florida
then she goes to florida no we gotta we
we are like
ground zero for the united states in
like raging
pandemic uh cases covent cases
now you know uh right around easter good
friday
everybody i'm not gonna lock it down
again
and it's now the date is coming i i'm
not a
pen uh a covert denialist in any way you
know
try to be a good boy try to respect me i
got his mask i caught it i'm over it
that's why i'm not wearing it
you know i'm not a freak but
she says uh listen don't travel to
florida because it's really bad there
and they got uh this
uk variant uh we and they and i think
maybe
we got it from them number one
her chief operating officer who's in
charge of
distributing the vaccine
beats it down to margaritaville she's in
the siesta key or
something like that and um meanwhile
whitmer's on the day is telling biden
give us the vaccine
unaware that the coo didn't order the
360
000 vaccines that were waiting for us
because she's down to margaritaville
wow with the teeny boppers while her
18 year old son is back home with covet
so you're traveling around with teeny
boppers you've been exposed to covid
and you're the chief operating officer
of the state so i get on to the next one
spring break the department of health
and human
services the chief medical director for
michigan
beats it down to margaritaville they
want to play funny with me
i know it you know i know it this you're
going to confirm it or deny it because
you know i already know it
but where's margaritaville like what are
you referencing that would that be like
the gulf
like we're from michigan so these people
are traveling down to the gulf or
whatever they're they're they're
partying they're leaving pandemic
central
after they locked us down governor told
us all to stay put
try not to go down there do the right
thing
and her two top health advisors are down
there let me catch him
part three did you go governor
did you go she did didn't she because i
know you went
she did because i'm a reporter
i know people all over the place there's
nothing going to happen we don't know
about
but click on's not going to do it
npr's not going to do it i'll leave it
to you to
ask why they won't do it this is
germaine
so the governor now says well i didn't
go on spring break i went to see my
ailing father
snowbird mansion west palm beach
[Laughter]
my brother died my brother died three
weeks ago that's not funny
i couldn't be at his deathbed people
couldn't go to funerals
people couldn't see loved ones in the
nursing homes
and you're making some cockamamie excuse
like this
this is not leadership
it's not everything's turned upside down
brother
our children's lives they're manic
they're sad they're confused right
they're staring at screens
we did what we were asked we did not
we thought we all row in the boat
together
when you know the top three officials in
michigan did this
that boat has sailed and when i flew
into charlotte
north carolina this morning whew that
was packed i felt like gulliver's travel
or
rip van winkle like i haven't seen a
crowd like this in
a year and a half and i'm i'm
personally disgusted
and you can parse you can fake it
here's what will not be written about
the coveted response
it happened in an election year history
will not remember
this is the most important election of
our lifetimes
that's right okay they won't remember
the games that everybody was playing
everybody was playing everybody right
left and middle
history is segmented it's really
interesting when people talk about
the spanish flu for instance often they
don't talk about world war one
they just have to read about it you're
like oh wow that kind of happened
simultaneously for the most part
there are a lot of times in history
where people will reference something
like
the great depression and then you got to
understand the context around world war
one before it and
what what led up to these things but you
know we do a couple we do we do these
things with history
the story was the pandemic you're right
in 100 years they'll be like the
pandemic
there will be a separate historical
moment where they'll read about the
election
but they won't be in the same context
yes how we got jimmied
we got gamed again i don't want to sound
like a
denialist because i've never seen in my
lifetime the hospitals
overflow so that's true
do not even tweet me anything about that
that's true
but who did it hit
one more time the institutionalized
elderly
the very thing the government's
responsible for so when i see fauci
doing his morning talk shows
what is the nursing home strategy sir
because we now know before kovid 400
000 people died in the nursing home a
year
from communicable diseases wow and 550
000 died from covid
we gotta covert every year in these
places
now biden wants to come with 400 billion
to deal with it okay that's good so but
before we
crap that money down a hole you want to
tell me specifically what we're doing
or are the orange juice contractors
going to eat it up
so she is you're you're you're talking
about
what they did with putting coveted
patients in nursing homes yeah they took
they took the positive and put them in
with the
with the healthy to
clear out the hospital so you uh i guess
you're suing i'm suing the state
of michigan for this
we've come up with an asterisk we have a
death count
and then there'll be an asterisk vital
record search
so we add those in okay
when did they die they won't tell us how
old were they
they won't tell us what was their race
they won't tell us and specifically
where was the primary residence was it a
nursing home
are you pulling a cuomo here are we
trying to
hide statistical
deaths to make it look better because
look
as you add more deceased people do a
list
and less of the deceased people come
from a nursing home
you look like a winner why won't you
give it to me
this is our data why do i have to sue my
this is not the soviet union i think
the reason is probably obvious isn't it
because the number's probably bad like
with
what cuomo did even as right today as we
stand we're no better than
average which is what we like to say in
michigan
we did know better no worse hmm hmm
until the data comes out teacher
rednecked account
and he'll start counting what happens if
it comes out and the data comes out and
shows that it's a lot worse
that's bad now here's the thing what
happens if they give me the data
and it shows what they're reporting to
be true
guess what i'm going to do i'm going to
write that
that's the honest and dignified and
professional
thing to do i just don't think we have
journalism anymore
you know i guess we we we don't have
real reporters anymore
we do should we just name a few but
there's a small hand
okay we'll name them do that let's do
that before we dog
the whole institution it's not true i'll
give you one you give me one ready all
right
paul league i can give you matt tybee
i can give you the national ones
christine mcdonald i'm yeah i'm going to
give you
so who are they tell me who these people
are i'm doing it they're um
they're people in michigan that do good
work you know i'll give you that i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll
i'll i'll i'll i'll quickly
i'll correct myself look there are a lot
of good local reporters out there doing
really good work
yes i end up following a lot of these
guys uh men and women
when there's there's breaking news and
it comes from a certain area or a
certain city
i know that for the most part if you go
to a local reporter
it's usually pretty good these people
aren't the ones chasing the national
story and grifting to try and make it
the national people chase them
exactly and they should be paid more
right and they should be respected
and i don't want to dog them because i
know in minneapolis they're for real
in chicago and l.a i i know
pancho ortiz in mcallen texas that guy
does both
sides of the border oh no there's a lot
of us
so we're not dogging reporters
we're dogging the business i'll tell you
this
i think you're right i think i should
correct my statement again the problem
is
the powerful moneyed interests that fund
all this stuff
are not the local journalists who are
actually reporting on what's going on
give me it again brother that's right
right it is these powerful national uh
wealthy interests that are funding
who runs the newspapers now hedge funds
yeah
they're tearing them up you're right the
local newspapers are collapsing
they can't compete with the national
newspapers are over but
i love newspapers you know why they're
the best
kindling for a natural fire there's
nothing better than the news
one it's like a fireplace yeah it is
it's
i don't know what else you use to start
yeah you actually you ball it up and
it helps get things going i mean i mean
newsrooms in general right
you used to have men it's crazy when i
drive to some of these small towns you
see a big ol it's like the so-and-so
gazette or whatever and i'm like they
used to have a newspaper here
not anymore they don't have a web uh
newspaper
because they can't compete the national
level yeah the ads have become
you know google and facebook contributed
to this but it's also that the new york
times can serve local ads
so the big players dominate the market
if you live
in the middle of nebraska and you go you
go to these big prominent news websites
you're gonna get ads for the middle of
nebraska you're gonna get ads for
your local grocery store so you don't
need the local paper selling ads anymore
and then if people are like if i'm gonna
pay for news i'm gonna pay for the new
york times why would i pay for a local
paper
100 so what i do with my podcast
is i try in the week
to do one big solid story so when i do
it
that's hours and only hours and we beat
everybody and you gotta chase us
for instance saturday is the seven year
anniversary of flint
i bet you nothing was going to happen in
the great state of michigan until i just
said that
did they they they finally fixed the
pipes right i got you
hello everybody at home i got you hello
new york times
i got you remember flint
they finally fixed the pipes right yeah
no yeah man
still bad nah man it's like you know you
know what i got in flint
orange drink they they got that
news click no they didn't so it's still
bad
ain't nobody drinking the water in flint
yeah what did it do to us
flint what else
i was thinking like i think it's always
been
bad for humans you know it's always been
like we're struggling to survive we're
lucky to be alive
and now it's just less bad
but like there's still lead in the water
like there's not feast we
we have clean drinking water which is
kind of a first in humanity i guess the
romans maybe
started too so
it's not like it's falling apart it's
never really been that great
you know well but look come on it you'd
be better off in the middle of the woods
finding a dirty puddle and drinking it
than you would the water in flint
they had chemical plant runoff and they
had lead eroding in the pipes it's not
that bad now i mean but
i i would like to actually go back and
have a
muddy water and some and some land
that's mine
and some you know like one of these
bbc movies about the vikings where i'm
running around you know and
shooting elk and stuff yeah i wouldn't
mind that but you don't live very long
i thought we were supposed to be
improving i smell rot
that's what you've been talking i think
i think no matter how much technology
improves there's always the struggle of
maintaining things
like we still have people who live in
the middle of the wilderness we still
have people with their i mean they're
undiscovered tribes
we could develop all the best technology
in the world and i still think there
would be poor people who are living in
in squalor yeah the world's getting
crowded isn't it
yeah or is a great philosopher once
wrote
what goes up must come
down spinning wheels
going around do you think who was that i
don't know
[Laughter]
dj thomas or something we could evolve
to a place where humans are all like
consciously aware awesome connected
unified or are we always going to have a
segment of people that are like
dumb like kind of dumb animals that need
to be herded
i kind of like both
i like the dumb animal
and the superhuman because remember what
freud really said break it down
the civilized person and the animal
person
the you know the wider they get from
each other the more unhappy you are the
more anxiety
the animal gives up his pleasure for
longevity that's the civil person
that's really i thought he was brilliant
that's really what's going on
in our lives are we gonna be animals are
we gonna be civil or
i like being both you're gonna have a
good mix man
you gotta you gotta think long term you
gotta but people don't want us to be
that
no they wanna be short-term they don't
want us to be they don't like the animal
part of us
right there they wanna be relatively
nice you have to be nice and be nice at
work
raise your hand raise your hand don't
say wash your hands
and don't say the wrong words because
for so long tell it to the hand
the animals get angry they start banging
the bars and then they start ripping
things down and blowing things up and
that's what
the the government and the people in
power are afraid that there's going to
be some sort of chaotic
i don't even call it revolution but
chaotic evolution or de-evolution
so they're like no we have to create
strict rules we want these people to be
to follow us that we want us we want
them to use our money that we say
and i think it's it's holding us back
from turning into
like the homo sapien is going to evolve
into some other type of hominid or some
a bunch of different types of robots bro
and cybernetic
a brain in a jar connected to a car
battery yes
yeah that's exactly what we're about to
become all the above that's one way to
put it
psychics there'll be wild animal humans
there will be humans on mars
that are like bigger there will be
humans in deep space that are really
long we're gonna cybernetic
is for a lot of these these wealthy
industrialists elon musk neural link
to integrate humans with machines well
why wouldn't we because look
we already we tethered ourselves to one
we got we're interfacing with these
machines right now yeah but this one
yeah these for sure but this one is part
of me
this phone is and if you make it so i
could stick it inside myself and never
lose it at the bar
i might do it what if they hack it well
and then start making you think crazy
things and all of a sudden you just go
nuts
that's called marriage oh yeah
yeah a lot of people are worried about
the neural links stuff because it's so
much we got it we gotta discover but
my response to the neural links stuff
when people are like would you get it oh
i wouldn't get it i'm scared it's like
let the technology happen before you
start talking about whether you're
worried about it or not
this is exponential if i went if i went
to you
15 years ago and said would you want to
put a tracking device in your pocket
where the government can see where
you're going and
and big corporations know when you're
pooping you'd be like no way i never do
that now you're like i love this thing
but i go like what do i get for it
access to the summation of human
knowledge i would be like that's
interesting
maybe in fact we did
so it's no use going back and asking the
the question we all knew that right
yes yeah people are going to neural link
right up did you see terminator 2
you guys seen the movie i'll be back
again i thought it was uh like a
dystopian fantasy when i saw it
in the 90s and now i'm realizing
whoa dude that might actually happen
that's crazy that machines could
we we give over to this thing and then
it takes control
do you see the new terminator where i
guess like the machine
nanoparticles infected the dude and he
became a cyborg person or something
so in like one of the later movies i
don't they made too many of these
like i guess what what's what's the name
of the kid john connor is that yeah
yeah he he apparently gets infected by
nanotech which integrates him with
skynet or whatever
and he was like i guess the story was
something i could be getting wrong so
correct me in the comments if i'm wrong
he said something like skynet realized
they couldn't win so they decided to
integrate with humans and they're like
quick kill him i'm like wait wait wait
what's wrong with that like he's he's
super powerful
he's like basically indestructible he's
still him he's doing his thing
wouldn't you want nanobots to make you
know it's like tony stark in the in the
in the
in avengers where he presses the butt on
his chest and then he gets a suit of
armor
wouldn't you want to be suit like have
superpowers
not only that i'd like to be the
governor of california
yeah afterward would be fantastic as
well when you retire
so you don't get the analogy do you
arnold schwarzenegger
oh you did get the analogy yeah
terminator we'll just we'll just take
that out and
uh this is live post-production so what
imagine this you didn't tell me that you
didn't know it was live
i didn't mean that i didn't mean it i
love you
so so imagine right now when we're all
like we're okay with these phones in our
pockets tracking our every movement
because of the powers we get from it
i gotta say like okay you gotta
integrate with the machines but you can
also have super powers you could jump
real high your hand could turn into a
sword
but bro i just i turned off location and
i just wanna check facebook that's not
how it works
even if i turn location off it means yes
yeah really yes no and i i told all the
apps you can't track me yeah
they can track you welcome to the future
crazy thing is you don't know i mean let
me explain something proprietary let me
actually i actually thought i was
getting away with it with a vpn and
turning it all off
you just don't know hold on what the
code is doing behind your back
in order to connect to the vpn it has to
connect to a local tower first
true and it has to register your device
on that tower first
put a vpn in it vpn protects your
browsing
so like if you're looking up you know
pictures of dogs they won't know you're
looking at pictures of dogs
but they'll they will know where you're
you you are at hitting that tower
they can ping me oh yeah yeah your top
your phone has to be like hey this is
charlie's phone i want to do something
i'm not going to tell you what it is
that's different
so yeah you're being trained let me
explain some to you
you know that you have voice activation
on the phone right yeah you you can say
uh what is you know you know the phrase
i don't want to say it because i want to
turn people's phones down
hey judy machine you say hello phone and
it turns on
yeah how does it know you're talking
because you
allowed it to access your voice and how
does it know you're talking at that
moment
um because i press the button no no you
can activate it without pressing the
button by saying its name
what goes up i can say we got we got one
of the amazon devices right
it's just sitting there in the room
listening but if i say it's name it'll
turn on and say what would you like
in fact if you go to if you go to your
settings it'll act you can look up the
things you've said to your device and
it'll say
this was not intended for the for you
know name of device that means
your phone right now in order for it to
be able to know
you used a voice activation command the
microphone is
always on always
the way voice activation works
the way the voice activation the way the
voice to text works
you say a word the phone sends that
sound byte to a company that tran
that codes takes that sound and turns it
into text okay
sends it back that means help me how do
i get rid of that
throw out the window that's the only way
well you could use options
wait wait no for the regular people how
do i get rid of that
you can't then don't carry a phone yeah
no no carry a mini faraday cage
what's what all right so faraday cage
is like it's it's a i love that it was
robin williams and nathan lane
in the fairly cage all right the bird
catch the bird cage
great movie by the way farah day cage
blocks all
incoming electromagnetic waves and
outgoing
is that an app no no it's a little box
made of metal
okay so so so you ever look at the front
of a microwave and you can see that like
you can kind of see in but there's a
metal screen yeah that's because the
holes are the right wavelength to
prevent microwaves from coming out
a microwave is a faraday cage because
that's to keep all the microwaves inside
of it
if you put your i'm pretty sure this
works if you put your phone in the
microwave it should put your phone
like on untrackable because but my
head's going to explode
you can't don't put it in my microwave
don't put your head in the microwave
you could get a 5g what does it know the
5s
or if your android i think the 5s and
before
you could take the battery out and that
won't no
uh i don't think they can track a phone
without a battery in it not the old ones
no i'm talking about when the battery's
in it and i'm just here now these
batteries are permanently in now
okay get a burner phone no no that won't
work come on
why so the burner the burner phone still
has to register on a tower right yeah
but don't
link it to your name then if you at any
point ever have that phone and your
phone
in this in the same place at the same
time the network will register both
devices
do that a couple of times and they will
and the the ai tracking these systems
will detect a pattern
this cell registration and this
registration appear in the same time
how far away should i use my burner
phone from my regular or turn my regular
phone off
when i use my burner phone leave your
regular phone at your house go a few
miles for your burner phone
what if i turn my burner phone i mean my
regular phone
off and then use my burner phone it
might work but i'll tell you this
just go a couple miles you don't you
need to understand something
they have a facebook train honestly no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no for for sure for sure
do you have a facebook profile yeah do
you have any family members who never
signed up for facebook
yeah they have facebook profiles too
even though they didn't sign up they're
called shadow profiles
i know that i know so the point is
if they want to track your burner phone
it is as
easy as making chocolate chip cookie
dough
i'm going to give you my number on my
burner phone
don't do it you know i heard your code
not on this show check this out check us
out
911. no no no no no no no no no no we i
was at a meeting
in uh don't dial that number i was at i
was at a google event
and i was there no you can't do that man
i was at a google event with uh who is
that who's that famous war correspondent
for nbc
richard engel is that his name yeah
richard angle yeah he still
he went to syria during the height of
the war with his cell phone
he brought his cell phone his personal
phone with him into syria and i was just
like
bro are you joking and he was like no
why it's like anything on your phone
just consider it the property of the
syrian government at this point
the moment you landed within their
towers they owned every bit of data on
that phone probably
instantly they they're tracking this
stuff it's war bro dude he didn't
realize you know it's funny
like just it go ahead brother i mean i'm
going off on another tangent about how
the world is becoming all
like observable we're all like becoming
part of this board collective whether we
want to or not
it's crazy like how are we going to
navigate this new reality well you have
to be smart like he's saying because
we our supreme court justice is on a
junket to dubai
and he's supposed to be in israel and he
gets stopped for covert they decide to
spend three
three months the state the supreme court
yeah and he decides to spend three
months in dubai but he says
i'm working and i'm like are you doing
conferences
by a zoom you know those are supposed to
be secret
those are undercover which cases we're
picking when we're discussing the merits
of the case and how we're going to come
up with the decision
and you're doing it by zoom in dubai
the government's got all that and nobody
nobody questions no that's right there's
no way to do business
there's no way to run a government they
they
they got everything man facebook they
know everything about you facebook can
predict
when you poop they can because that's
when i'm checking it out
it's not just that it's that based on
simple things like when you last eight
they know when you ate because they're
checking your location it's not even
about whether or not you have location
services on
some there's some services that have
mapped out all of the local wi-fi
signals from certain areas so
when you are they'll have cars drive
around and they have a computer
scanning open wi-fi signals they're not
breaking into your wi-fi
they're just seeing who's broadcasting
they then incorporate that into map
data so that way you can use your your
map app whichever one without having
access to gps do we care
i'm looking up zoom apparently it's
owned by eric yohn chinese immigrant
non-american citizen but the company's
development team is largely based in
china
meaning all that stuff's property oh
yeah every every communication you do on
zoom is probably in the chinese chinese
service chinese government's got it
oh so the supreme court justices yeah
it's compromise this
this world is we care not yes
i do but they're gonna be slaves well
like how do we
how do we survive it that's basically
it's happening i mean i'm not trying to
like
be like stop stop i don't want my my
life to be
in the public domain because it
basically is but how do we
survive that planet species is becoming
the borg
i don't want to yeah you can't stop so
we have to leave the planet
i don't know man just know if you raise
chickens you should feed him the
eggshells
is that true though i heard you're not
supposed to do that i heard you're
supposed to we went to a vet first
chicken and said make sure you don't get
any eggshells in there
oh no i fed him ever so we every two
days with those things we had
we had a sick chick and they said make
some scrambled eggs for
for the chick excuse me but just make
sure you don't put any
eggshells in it you're cooking
scrambled eggs that's the chicken that's
right yeah
unfertilized the reason they said not to
make sure it doesn't get any egg shells
is because
then they'll eat their own man for what
he was worried about his chicken he died
he loves his chickens and it does
that's how bad your cooking is no it's
just sometimes chickens die man
we brought to the vet the vet was like
sometimes chickens just weak they don't
make it the little babies you know what
do you think the vet thought when you
walked in with a
it was a chicken vet they were like
that's right they were like another
sticks another that's right we got farms
and they were like
their attitude was a customer is here
that's it
and they had chicken medicine and they
gave it to us and they gave us a little
thing you put in the chicken's mouth
because there are a lot of farmers who
had to treat their chickens is there a
pandemic going around
no but chickens have parasites is it
chikvid it's called
um what's it called what was it what was
it
well what the parasite the chickens can
get yeah i forgot it was trichonosis is
the face
there was there's there's something they
have i can't remember what's called
coccidiosis
interesting that's funny coccydiosis
yeah
so they have to give because like
roosters
[ __ ] city yeah you know you know the red
thing on the chicken's head
the the comb cock's comb yeah
but the chicken chickens have it too and
so like the hens have it so maybe
like we had some people like see the
chickens and like one of them like
they're growing up one of them's got the
little thing on and they're like but i
thought they were i thought they were
all girls i'm like yeah
they're like what they have has the red
thing i'm like chickens have that too
you know
how to have that do you guys feel like
like this last week has been dark
what do you mean dark this was this
chauvin thing and the way
yes i i feel kind of like not
demoralized or like
i'm still reeling like like what like a
loss a lack of hope
like like it's wednesday man don't worry
the week's
only half of those feels like friday
[ __ ] up bro
i want to see we got to go super chats
but i just want to point out i think
your chris cuomo bit is going to go down
in
in the show history of being like one of
the best clips where you're like okay
you went do it better
well i'm coming out i've been out of
here in a couple weeks
now go back down the basement
you got to watch that again and watch
his son's face while he's doing it
because
his son thinks he's such full of crap
he's watching he's like dude
he has not been down in the basement
this whole time he's lying and he's on
he got caught and he admitted it it's
crazy did you pop your headphones out i
don't know where that goes
okay here can you we'll read super chats
and then i can hear you guys charlie's
his headphones out by the way before we
go hey brother
it's good to see you again oh yeah dude
it's been amazing
i love you man i think the last time we
hung out was in ferguson
wow and it was it was crazy times when
we hung out the bar it was fun
the bar not the ferguson yeah that's
kind of clever thing about the business
man it's
it's uh hard if you do it right it's
horrifying
and you you know we're going to read
some super chats lydia will help fix
your
fix your headphones all right everybody
if you haven't already smash that like
button
helps a shout out leave a comment we
really appreciate it go to timcast.com
because we're gonna have an even more
entertaining
members only exclusive with charlie lee
duff coming up later tonight i can swear
yeah and the members only stuff you can
you can
i did well didn't it you tried so hard
yeah we don't swear on the live shot
because we're family friendly
but uh so go to teamcast.com become a
member we also got a bunch of big
updates we're working really hard on
getting this done it's not the easiest
thing in the world we're hiring tons of
people
but uh let's read some super chats we
got the first super chat from a name
that's being blocked by youtube
he says what are your thoughts on ranked
choice voting
i'm a fan i like ranked choice voting me
too
i look at a lot that means so you have
ten candidates you give them each a
ranking on one to ten
and then if your number one choice it
isn't one of the contenders it defaults
to your number two
right and then it takes like the top two
final contenders
and it will calculate which one of them
goes to those two
yes so it's not perfect system by any
means it still can devolve into a
two-party system but the idea is
so if you had you know uh who why joe
jorgensen
trump and we had biden you could be like
okay trump's number one joe jorgensen's
number two biden's number three
if trump doesn't pull enough votes your
votes flips to the next
choice that way the idea is the person
who wins is more representative of what
the people want as opposed to first past
the post voting
where everybody gets one vote and then
that person wins which creates a
two-party system
so i i like the idea my turn yeah
too confusing in a country of 330
million people that don't even trust a
mail-in ballot
no but it's it's going to be confusing
it can be like please please select your
choice for president it's it's lightning
round i'm just saying but check it out
here's
imagine this please select your choice
for president you go check i know what
it is
then a box of appearances who who else
would you like to be president if this
was
your second choice and you could pick
somebody not in the dna
next super question but first
all right then kb toys says the majority
voted to abolish the police
does that mean we disregard the minority
then you criticize those who wouldn't
let their car be taken
but advocate abandoning cities you live
another day and are out of the fight
uh i think that if you're there's a big
difference between someone trying to
steal your car
outright where it's illegal and no one
agrees with stealing cars
i think if you're in a city and they
pass a bill that says carjacking is now
legal and you're like i'll stay here
then what do you want me to say when you
get carjacked so look
if it's illegal to carjack somebody and
someone carjacks you
you my personal opinion is you know
to to to certain degrees of course i'm
gonna be like i'm gonna fight
but if uh if your city
legalizes or decriminalizes carjackings
you might want to leave
yeah but not everyone can not you know
it's
hard for people to relocate sometimes
sure we did have a super chat yesterday
where someone
pushed back on that saying it's not as
hard as people think
and i look man the fact of the matter is
hard or easy isn't isn't is it isn't
what's important what's important is
if you stay in a city like minneapolis
what you are saying is
it is easier and safer for me to stay
here than it would be to leave
because i tell you this you got a family
it's tough you seriously could just
start walking
nothing stopping you and your family
from just walking down the street and
walking now i get it
that's ridiculously unsafe so it might
be safer to stay in your home
but finding a new place to live running
apartment might be hard but you might be
safer in the long run it's short-term
versus long-term thinking
are we on the family-friendly show or
the other show
uh yeah so it's um
now legal to come up to me at the gas
station stick a gun on my face and take
my car
stupid is it well you know
it's carjacking as far as i know what it
is yeah yeah i'm not saying it is legal
i'm saying
you live in minneapolis where they've
tried to abolish their police yeah
it backfired a bunch of cops left and
now people are panicking
staying there is kind of like a bad idea
that's just my opinion you can stay if
you want all right ernie g says
detroit's best journalist love your work
charlie tim lydia and sometimes
ian i was a bit teed off by the no good
80s music ac dc motley crew
who said no good 80s because guns and
roses i didn't say there was no one else
what was it you i mean i was dogging on
80s just the 80s in general the 80s was
one of the best music periods
ever don't you want me baby except for
the 60s and the 70s and the 90s
the 70s 70s there's good there's good
70s
yeah was hot look look at this
activities
depressed mode i mean come on the 90s
was when rock and roll was birthed
you could say it it was birthed before
that but the night it matured in the 90s
the 90s had smashing pumpkins i'll give
you that yeah
it had a lot of that grunge the seattle
yeah the seattle
sound the 80s was was had some good
music no no doubt
guns and roses is like one of the best
bands of all time i think true
it is it's the 2000s that was bad right
yeah when autotune took hold
the 2000s were bad so bad what do we
have in 2000 somebody told us their
stuff and i was like oh yeah that
that that existed there's some good
stuff but when auto tunes
came out anyone could just like sing
crappy and then tweak it
and like the whole point i think of
recording yourself is to make it sound
like
who you are for real and there's a
challenge to sound good
like justin bieber
dave in 50 years people are going to be
putting on the classics justin bieber
oh god all right we got doc doc
hollandaise says
thanks for introducing me to charlie
he's a blast there you go
dw says never heard of this guest but
why does he sound like he does a
voiceover from mobster movies
none of your business
i hate to think about that but i wasn't
gonna come up with a good one but it's a
family
uh stay tuned for the next one subscribe
if you're not
and i'll tell you why all right cicantia
says once again i am asking for your
support
to bring donut operator or angry cops in
the podcast much love to you all
even ian who catches my friend and i
have guard with federal reserve rants
yes love a trans girl trump voter all
right uh donut operator would be
fantastic
i reached out to him recently okay cool
yeah wait that's something hey
trans girl trump voter aspect
respect yeah man hmm gerald
herbert says stink bugs are also known
as kissing bugs
as they eat dead flesh and the lips are
their favorite to feed on at night
and they care about carry horrible
bacteria that can cause fatal infections
how nice
thank you and they don't degrade there
are two they don't degrees of stinkpot
you live
and your belly come out so we we've been
just we've thrown them in jars we go
outside we've thrown a chicken thing and
chickens just go nuts
they love stuff i can see why they were
not i would eat them
they're they're they're big and juicy
good and crunchy
jack jack mack says oh i'm sorry jack
mcdoug boy oh
my buddy in ukraine says everyone is
super on edge he lives less than 50
miles from the russian border
worried about my homie and the world
yeah alone man
this is it look at this black lion grunt
says russia warns u.s
and nato to not cross their red line i
wish we had a strong leader like a
certain orange man
but you know the history of the ukraine
and poland and
central europe they get washed over all
the time
that's right but now we got really
big bombs not a good idea
very true all right steve smith says
damn i vote for the first time in 2016
in the world seems to go to crap
well it's a good thing it's cold in
minnesota tonight so less riots maybe
also i feel a lot like the cops have
debt so they won't quit thus they stick
around
in this terrible system yeah well there
you go hey keep in mind man
maybe it seems like it's going to crap
but it's not it just seems like that
because of the media manipulation
but i like what dude said though you
know like it's a job
it's a job it should pay more it should
pay more that's
end the story but you're right i don't
think people i don't think people
realize that
having people who don't who don't feel
invested in their work because they get
paid garbage
it's like thirty eight thousand yeah and
can i do this
because i a lot of my friends are cops
every single person out there knows
that the majority of cops do a hard job
and they do it well
we know that we should say that and ask
nobody even knows what force continuum
means
you're asking for a change that you
won't even understand what it is to be a
police
so i just want to shout out to the very
good police tonight
all right conor o'brien says the only
piece of journalism i'll show my
grandkids is the clip of al roker
fessing up to crapping his pants in the
white house
is that real i don't know that's what it
is
that sounds real it does sound real
all right let's see where we at
tennessee
pharaoh fox says glad to see charlie is
still doing great things
loved your book ish show keep flashing
that press badge and not wearing the
brown shoes
and spin the ufo which we actually we
don't have we have the spinny thing
uh but the uh the ufo still exists i
want to get a spinning moon
we had what happened to the earth
remember we had the earth yeah the earth
is flat
no it doesn't okay depends on how you
look at it that way how's that a thing
some people just kind of lost they used
to think it was
there was like ancient you know it's not
giants didn't they have like no
firmament and there was a belief that it
was on the back of a turtle or something
yeah
i mean i don't know about all that i do
know that ancient i do know that
arastosthanes calculated the
circumference of the earth by
measuring shadows and that was in like
two bc that dude's name is awesome by
the way
this is a nice pronunciation one one in
um
athens and one in cairo in fact that's
right yeah yes
there's many ways so smart dude that's
amazing look at so this look at the
look at the eclipse right it's circular
the idea we have
a flat sir it looks like a flat circle
from so if the earth is flat
is it up on the side like a quarter or
is it flat
see what i'm saying maybe it's up on its
side and and and doing this
the speed of light okay it looks like a
scale yeah the idea is
actually yeah the idea that the earth
was flat was uh like christopher
columbus
that's not true yeah oh the issue was
columbus thought the earth was a smaller
circumference and that
the academics were wrong they all they
all knew it was round you know why
because boats go over the horizon and go
down like people weren't dumb they were
like oh look at that it's a
it was always so let me give the visual
if may i
yeah sailors know this
when uh when a ship with the with the
mass and the sails when they come over
the horizon the first thing you see is
the crow's nest
then you see the main sail then you see
the bow
so if the earth was flat you'd see them
all at the same time they'd just be
small
right but you see them rising up over
the horizon that's how you curvature
yeah yeah and so that they've done that
for a long time and that's why he was
like i'm going to calculate the
circumference
so columbus was all like you're wrong
about how big
the planet is we can make it sailing
west
to india he just was wrong
and he ended up crashing into the
bahamas or something and then he called
everyone indians that's right
because he thought he was in india all
right anyway
k lorraine says i love this man i want
to see him on a show well you got a show
it's
an obs news hour yeah but look at that i
uh
i've been eating well and you look right
you know
cut my own hair trim my mustaches for
this show thank you i feel
i feel a little old i feel it coming on
and
thank you make me feel sexy all right
rabbit boy wants to feel sexy
rasgrizz missed a word but i'm going to
try and put in what i think they were
saying
charlie's outburst was the best i have
ever seen i am currently crying from the
hot sauce that just came out of my nose
get that man another beer on me
i'm telling you the cuomo thing is gonna
we're gonna clip that and we're gonna
make sure we we promote that one they're
bozos
and they're the same time right they're
like daddy's boy i mean
their dad mario cuomo is basically the
name recognition got them their jobs i
don't think they're really all that
great
yeah um i i i this this is a good idea
from eric a he says ian i have this
image of you coming in like the kool-aid
man
with end the fed and free the code it
wouldn't be the same show without you
maybe we have to make a shirt of ian
breaking through a brick wall with a
picture of
red fruit drink that says end of fed on
it a destructible wall
you can't end the fed we'll talk about
this yeah we should audit it at least
we could remember that would be good you
could also audit the pentagon
we could repeal the federal reserve act
of 1913.
you need the federal reserve act you
just need a bank but it doesn't have to
be the federal reserve oh
okay we're going to talk everybody's
everybody's having a good time look we
got we got some more we got some more
praise for you for you charlie
clayton praise i like faith tell me how
great i am oh yeah clayton says just got
to say what an amazing guest
i mean charlie is super entertaining in
every aspect
beau jess says thank you so much for
having charlie on he's doing great work
for my state and need as much support as
possible
yes charlie please never let up on
gretch and the corruption in michigan
fix the s i gave you a shirt you gave me
a
shirt we don't swear but it's just yes
fix the ish we'll fix it
government just fix it and we'll we'll
do our own stuff we don't need a nanny
man we're screwed
jay lavelle says dharmak and jalad at
tanagra
dharmak and jalad on the ocean kiazi's
children their faces wet
shaka when the walls fell uzami with
fist closed temba
when the walls fell the beast of tanagra
huh now if you guys know what that means
you have my respect
uh i dig it though but they mentioned
shots actually listening to that
so uh do you guys want to know what all
that meant yes the secrets
what do you think what do you think it
might be relevant to this show
oh he said shaka uh relevant to this
show
wakanda forever something we do here i
don't know something we reference quite
often i don't know
the federal reserve no cryptocurrency
graphene
no dmt that's all i got you give up yeah
you can't get it yeah it's a star trek
reference
oh okay i knew it it was the speaking
klinger
no it's an alien race that speaks in
parables and stories like my spanish
so when communicating and they would say
something like
uh dharmak and gelato in the ocean it's
a story
and you're communicating through uh oh i
saw that
so the idea is like when you say like
tim and ian
on tim cast you're basically saying like
having a discussion in arguments oh yeah
so it's like that reference is a
reference to the common occurrence
yeah okay yeah sorry if you were to say
something like
a nerd out over there mother raising her
child
on this busy street it's like well it's
a specific story so it's like
joe biden climbing airplane stairs so
you'd be referencing someone failing at
something indeed
is this pig latin or something no no
it's it's speaking it's
conveying ideas through stories it was
it was an episode i
didn't understand the damn word that guy
said because because so there's an
episode of star trek where they're
trying to communicate with these aliens
right who are frustrated because they
keep speaking in stories
and we can understand the words
specifically like ocean but we don't
know what the stories are so we have no
idea what they're saying
okay and so they're trying to translate
and then picard like
teams up with the guy and they're trying
to teach him the language and stuff like
that still confusing
try cockney 43
rub-a-dub aiden says hey tim love the
amount of work that you put into the
show
and as well as of the vids you make
throughout the week at the college i go
to they are making us go through
diversity and inclusion training because
of that girl from ohio
which girl that was one of the knights
okay
was it the one is that what they're
talking about i don't know how many
girls probably yeah there's one yeah
columbus yeah i don't make light of it
though it's
very s this sucks disturbing
yeah painful all right i i i've there
was a bunch of comments where they
really love you but we got to read the
ones where they don't oh yeah you ready
yeah ready okay music music dc guy says
this guy is a constitution hater and a
liberal apologist i'll tune back in
tomorrow
okay bro okay recite the preamble
or give me the three articles setting up
the confederation no no article one
article two article three give give me
give me the bill of rights can anybody
give me the bill of rights
thou shall not no those are these that's
the three commandments
i'm begging the most no huh any anybody
yeah
i'm not the guy that's right dude so
don't you even
do that without typing in now and we'll
see if you don't don't google it
you know you don't know it okay zach
says lola bunny
turning men into furries since 1996 yeah
that's bugs's uh girlfriend right so one
of the biggest scandals now apparently
is that lola bunny in 1996 was drawn
with big
big boobs and now they've gotten rid of
the boobs
so now lola bunny has no boobs by the
way
did you guys i don't think anyone's
actually mad about that oh then that's
just people are joking about it
they're just bugs bunny have you guys
seen the new looney tunes
freakishly disturbing they remade it
like seinfeld
where bugs is like jerry and but it's
just poorly poorly that you gotta watch
it dude it's so from when when
recently like five years old or three
years old or something really it's so
weird
is it like crude no it's just like
boring pseudo-humor it's so weird dude
can i get some more hate
he's inviting me for a conversation
martin edgar says
grandma got run over by a reindeer by
elmo
shropshire
educated audience here that's right sir
nioff stripes i say tim you should get
gary uh
biker he talks about how they just use
characters we know to push woke because
he was so in a comic shop and rise from
being a drug addict that went to jail
to a youtuber he said he would love to
be on love the show very cool uh we will
look into nerd roddick i will reach out
hey you're doing good man
alien king says you jumped out on your
own
stuff yeah i was i was working for a
disney company man
i couldn't i could have just done jumped
through all the hoops they asked me to
and got paid all the fat cash to be one
of the corporate shills i'm the only guy
that gets to come on here and say
i'm proud of you because i appreciate it
you were younger
we were in the spot together we know
each other we both worked for advice we
did
i'm proud of you thanks man oh thanks
charlie smart guy well thanks for coming
on the show let me let me read to you
what they're saying about you
alien king says what a great freaking
guest i love charlie's honesty candor
and energy
just imagine the life experiences this
guy has had take note and step up trevor
no right track we're not ragging on
trevor anymore
no no no just people never someone
called out their friend trevor so we all
started joking that trevor sucks
and then somebody named trevor was like
come on trevor noah what's up
dude you came over in in 2014
what do you know that's nice it's good
with the tears you don't know what tears
are not here
he's doing what he thinks jon stewart
would do and he's just
not jon stewart it's so
so cringey cringe says can you please
trim these youtube videos i don't listen
to a minute and a half of dead air
before each episode keep it the good
work
i don't think we actually can i don't
think uh we test we've tried trimming
so this is a live show once it goes up i
don't think you can actually
oh actually you might be able to trim oh
can we you can't split it afterwards
yeah you can't split it right you know
it's live is posted then it's going to
archive it then you can go back and you
can cut we'll see if we can do that but
he's
live is the guy's life but
what's the matter with you but most
people do watch after the fact
i know but he's doing live like i can't
take it anymore i'll see what i can do
we'll see what i can do
frank sculla says charlie never heard of
you before but i gotta say you are one
heck of a character
i can't say i agree with everything you
said today but man i would share a beer
with you
brother we're not supposed to agree with
that's right with everything but i
definitely have a beer i think all that
people really want is
authenticity you can be wrong about a
ton of things and people would love to
hang out with you as long as you're
willing to
actually talk about it and that's the
thing like look there are a lot of
people we don't know each other that
well we don't agree with
everything but it's an interesting night
and you return to your corner of the
earth and i return to mine
and that's we're going to have to try
this we're going to have to have you do
a bunch of you know little
little mini docs for us though if you're
interested definitely look
man look here's the thing it's a new
media concern
i don't need you you definitely don't
need me
but why don't we link up sounds good
okay we'll figure it out here we go oh
we're gonna
kill oh we're going to a kill orwell was
a prophet 1984
says i love how the same people that
want to abolish the police also want to
take my guns that's adorable
you think a social worker is going to
actively listen me out of my stockpile
that's what i'm saying look you want to
abolish the police there won't be
anybody to enforce gun laws so
i'm not worried about it i got a nice
story about that real quick because
we're doing
rapid fire um in detroit one time they
sent the social worker
and the social worker for what got that
for what
uh disturbed man disturbed me social
worker went in
dude was naked had a shotgun said sit
down social worker sat down
in a barca lounger of urine
and had to sit there for an hour until
they got manchester united
they were all right yeah it turned out
all right but that's
good you don't just send social workers
we all
know what's going on let's be adults
about it
scott h says hey charlie i live in
detroit and have followed you since you
exposed bob ficano for serving cat food
to meals on wheels
similar to the orange drink keep
fighting the good fight exposing whitmer
serving cat food to old people long
story
wow man long story but again uh
no i'm not hunting whitmer let's get
this straight
i want answers and when the answers
aren't truthful
i keep going i'm not hunting i'm doing
what a report is supposed to do keeping
the government held to account that's it
right on alex moore says good job team
y'all make me laugh cry yell at the tv
throw the occasional can
agree and agree to disagree i will give
a super chat for one of you to finish
cyberpunk at least one ending
and think prophetic future when you
review for us
i'll tell you you've finished it i
haven't even bought it yet but i'll go
there
i guess they fixed a lot of it okay
that's that's what i was waiting for i
think i still have the original on my
playstation
like when it first came out so it's like
all the glitchy broken never been
updated erase you
probably auto updates whenever i play
skater xl or whatever
all right slayer says hey charlie i'm 26
living in detroit and i can't stand
uh gretchen are there any job
opportunities to work with you i'd love
to join you
um should i give my email yeah if you
want
if you feel you'll get like you've got a
lot a thousand emails
gmail.com dude but come if you're for
real you got some video skill
you know what i mean no i appreciate
it but i'm not running a community
college if you got some skills get a
hold of me if not
go to the community college get the
skills then get a hold of me
all right julie simone says while i
agree with personal accountability
and not staying in a place that no
longer aligns with your values
unfortunately there aren't as many
decent places for people to flee
so then what uh west virginia
wyoming flee what never flee first of
all don't flee
if you flee you're the problem you're
weak you make a choice to
move there's a difference
or hold it out and get real on planet
earth there's no disneyland
you said it never been that great no
it's not
so come on now don't flee
i don't trust you if you flee nobody
wants flight you never have my back if
you flee
that means you don't have your own back
interesting there are such things as uh
organized retreat that's a lot different
than getting routed
so heather graham says tim the supreme
court previously upheld that police
agencies have no
duty to provide protection to citizens
in general the other officers
in george floyd death had no duty to
provide protection to george floyd at
the very least correct
it's true i actually was looking at one
of luke rodkowski's old videos
there was a guy on a subway in new york
and a knife i guess and he was attacking
people
and the cops refused to do anything some
regular guy
tried subduing this guy with a knife and
the cops just stood there and watched
because they're like we don't got to do
anything we're not going to help you
so luke actually interviewed the guy he
got stabbed a bunch of times it's crazy
i remember that
yeah that's that's nuts what's up with
those other cops that were on the scene
for the
the chauvin i guess murder you would
call now i don't even like it i guess
oh there are no i i i think they're i
think
that their stuff proceeds now and they
were charged with like aiding and
abetting is that right
i don't know i'm gonna be honest with
you
i didn't follow all of this as closely
as everybody
i i just wasn't glued to tv i don't know
the specifics because
i know what i saw did you see the second
video
of of uh george floyd like before the
chauvin got there resisting that yeah
if if that's resisting that's the
weakest argument i
ever like scene kicking kicking your way
out of the car and knocking people down
dude i mean come on this this can't even
be
an argument here yeah so maybe he's a
little bit high so maybe he's a little
bit constantly should they let him go he
no what you do is you take them out you
stand them in the car
ready here's the real one you call the
paddy wagon
you call the van that's what you do
because they got
vans for the k-9 unit right if you won't
that's all you do
every district's got a van
go get a you all i'm going to kill them
i guess the issue is and i stand right
because the jury said so
that's it's officially murder officially
murder it was a murder
you're right if you believe in this
system it's just a democracy of ours
it's a murder we now say he's murdered
no i don't when he went because
snowden's very persecuted this was white
jesus over here assange is being
persecuted i don't i don't believe this
is not about face value
but in in terms of the formal official
statement yep murder yeah according to
the formal official statement tonight do
you think that
george flay was murdered no i think he
was high on opiates
and fentanyl and would have killed
someone and you i don't know
you know why i watched the trial from
start to finish
yeah i've seen the full body camera
footage and i and i heard
the the girlfriend of george floyd say
that he was in the middle of a drug deal
he was and that he ate a speed ball i've
been high and dope that he had
enough have you ever been choking me out
you know that he had 90
narrowing of the arteries around his
heart it was again choke me out
and then my 90s gonna turn to a hundred
but that's not murder you know he had
more than if you're high and about to
die and then someone i'm hiding about to
die in a compliment he got his
business on my neck they never proved
that they haven't proven what killed
george floyd
i know but so how do you prove murder if
you can't even prove the cause of death
beyond a reasonable doubt
this is getting all nice this is a big
conversation okay i've worked with
people who had drug addictions
i've worked with people who are
withdrawing from all kinds of drugs
and they had serious issues like this is
something that seriously complicates
your life so when i hear that george
floyd was high in fentanyl that's a
serious complicating factor
do you know that he had more than a
lethal dose of fentanyl in this he did
yes
did you know that he also combined with
the north fentanyl probably took the
drugs well before any interaction
happened
yes the judge even said it looked like
george floyd put fentanyl in his mouth
yes
he also had a high amount of
methamphetamine yes exactly according to
the state's
own witnesses chauvin was entitled under
the law to use a taser on george floyd
due to active resistance
george flor derek chovin chose to use
the lesser force option
the knee wasn't on his neck for nine
minutes and 29 seconds the prosecution's
own body camera footage that was shown
proved that chauvin actually moved his
knee off of george floyd's neck and onto
his back
several different times into his bag
george floyd actively resisted and
bystanders at first were yelling at
george floyd
to stop resisting arrest he did and
floyd said no
he did that they called for backup
derrick chauvin was called on a priority
one
six six foot one 220 pounds resisting
arrest that's true and chauvin chose to
use lesser force according to the
prosecution's witness and then again
that's all true
so how is it murder because intent to
kill you you got the business on the
man's neck knee put on his back he can't
breathe you knew he couldn't breathe we
all saw he couldn't breathe
you pick the man up and you make sure he
breathes well do you know can i go to
the bathroom you know
you know according to the state's own
witness the amount of that fentanyl
the most dangerous component of fentanyl
is that it who are you talking to
you you know who i come from do you know
my people do you know what i know about
fentanyl yeah and cocaine that's right
and alcohol yep my people i'm from the
south side of chicago i'm completely
understand
so i'm not going to buy that man so when
when when so
let's make the last point let me go to
the bathroom you asked me if i think
it's a murder and i'll tell you this
the witness for the prosecution said the
most
dangerous thing about fentanyl is that
it depresses your your respiratory
system and your ability to breathe
and results in hypoxia now you're going
to tell me
that excuse me brother
a very dear loved one of mine died this
past
july complications of fentanyl
just the fact that somebody gave it to
him is murder murder three and i can't
get no justice
nope so please let me go to bed yes
let's do it yeah well with that being
said actually that was a great end man
uh
we're gonna come back for the members
only segment over at timcast.com so make
sure you check that out
charlie's getting excited because he can
swear now i wanna shout out his website
uh we're gonna we'll be back at
timcast.com at about 11 with the members
only exclusive
so make sure you smash that like button
subscribe become a member
i can't wait to get more of this work
done and launch these new shows but
man doesn't take just so much work yikes
once we get the ball rolling and we can
get into the groove of things
but we're gonna have we're gonna have
news articles coming up hopefully we can
get this with get this
settled really really quickly but we
have a bunch of writers who are gonna be
coming on we're gonna have a bunch of
news articles on the site
we're going to get a bunch of guest
writers new shows tv shows all this
stuff i'm not joking
new vlog's coming up as well you can
follow me on all social media platforms
at tim cast but wait
follow us on instagram and facebook at
tim cast irl
with new clips from the show that you
can share
and help out the show by sharing so like
our facebook page teamcast irell
follow us on instagram tim cast irl and
you can check out my other youtube
channels
youtube.com slash timcast
youtube.comcastnews
and i don't know how you find this one i
guess if you look in the recommended
channels bar on this page we got
cast castle which is uh we might change
the name i don't know i decided to put
up the vlog
we're going to put it more we got
another vlog ready to go we're going to
be filming again this sunday it's going
to be a lot of fun and then eventually
we got someone coming in who's probably
going to be taking over and doing a
daily show
on the vlog channel which would be
exciting because you'll get to see the
guests behind the scenes hanging out in
the green room
it'll be awesome so uh well i guess
charlie is hitting the head uh ian you
want to shout your stuff out
yeah first i see got a tweet from you
earlier it says abolish the police hire
social workers instead i am 100
serious was that serious did i say it
was serious you did but i don't trust
anything you say on twitter
i said abolish the police and hire the
social workers you know why no because
the city's voted for it
yeah okay that was all i needed i'm at
this point where it's like dude
if if people are like this is what we
would like please i'll be like then let
him let him do it
i don't live there most people don't
live in new york like most people listen
to the show
listen man if if you are in if if you
want your your
like you live in a city where you're
fighting a good fight
but they've supported the riots i said
it a million times you probably
shouldn't be there anymore
you know should probably go find
somewhere else where you can
be more comfortable whatever if the
people want social workers
let them have social workers all right
it's like it's like a chinese finger
trap problem we're trying to get our
fingers out of this trap by pulling as
hard as we can maybe the solution is
actually to push the trap
take a pair of scissors and just cut it
in the middle but the thing is man
um the community in large is not calling
for that
it's made for tv sorry man they're not
they're not doing anything to stop it
so if if elections if elections have
consequences
they keep voting for leaders who push
this stuff okay and they don't care
about the consequences
it's a tough world because if the masses
believe something it's hard for them to
get that word out you get one individual
can make a youtube channel
so like one person kind of consolidates
power in the individual or
nbc and so they have the word i get from
detroit from the community
the people i know being on the block no
they support police they want good
professional you know non-uh
a-kicking police they got to come out in
the streets and show their support
they got to put up the flags they got to
say something because right now the
violent mob
the vast majority done didn't take to
the street unless they got a reason to
and if the cops get abolished they might
right i'm just going to shout out i want
more police
ian crossland.net which is my website
and that you can follow me at ian
crossland uh but also leduc
is back so yeah shout out your show man
and your social media what you got
what is your show called the no are we
on the
the new one no no we're still live one
yeah no bs
news hour yes no bs news and you're
you're charlie le duff
on twitter led i i don't remember
i see you follow zero people that's
awesome yeah
zero that's great so that's so much the
only man i ever followed was my
grandfather there you go
the rest i'll have a talk with but i use
the
the twitter's just to know what i'm
doing what's going on just like the no
bs newshour
sweet love it thank you thank you for
that that uh
now um when do we get to the part where
we can drink whiskey
in about five minutes it's really tough
give us five minutes let lydia shout out
and then we'll we'll get to that
can i go get a cigarette i actually have
my first beer ever on the show thanks to
charlie why don't you go grab yourself
a no no yeah yeah oh this was awesome
and
man this was awesome it's i love it so
much fun
fun guess there we go high fives all
around
heck yeah we're gonna be back with
charlie for the members only stuff he's
just gonna he's gonna grab a smoke
wait he's gonna give me a high five i
missed him here we go oh no my gosh no
we didn't see that we're good to go
thanks charlie fake news all right hold
on let me do a quick shout out yeah
we'll see what your hippies are doing
okay nice let's just try just come back
up because we're gonna i'm gonna but
they're watching tv and not doing
anything bro
yeah they're just hanging out that's not
good
okay so i got onto twitter and i was
kind of upset about the minnesota
thing because minnesota has voted blue
every single election since 1984.
okay you guys they know what they're
voting for they know what they're doing
they gave us ilhan omar they give us
keith ellison they
effing know what they're doing they're
blue
as heck and they understand what they're
voting for
so the fact that minneapolis is going
down in flames i honestly encourage
people to move out and toast your
s'mores
over the flames of minneapolis because
what else can you do
they understand what they're voting for
they know what they're doing anyway
enough incendiary talk i'm sarah
patchell it's on twitter if you want to
follow me
here's tim we will see you all at
timcast.com in about an hour or so with
the exclusive episode with charlie the
duff thanks for bringing out we'll see
you there
bye guys
you